everyone i'm jeff keeley and
welcome to a very special event a
conversation with christopher nolan
chris uh great to have you with us today
uh we are going to
chat about tenet also your career you as
a filmmaker and we've got questions
uh from the internet from fans around
the world who wanted to uh to chat with
you today and get some insight from you
so uh
i think we should just dive right in
let's talk again all right well um
the first question comes uh we're gonna
talk about tenant uh
first of all here and this one comes
from andy blackshaw and he wants to know
a simple question but how did you select
the title
tenet and i'm curious sort of in the
name but also in your
creative process like the the name of a
movie when does that come to you is it
early or late
i usually have a an idea early on
sometimes
a long time before in the case of 10 i
had the title
very early i mean years ago and
obviously the
the the fact that was a palindrome uh
you know was the
the sort of jumping-off point but it was
also um
what the word means it's the notion of
of belief
and for those who've seen the film
haven't seen the film
um and i try to be reasonably spoiler
free but uh
because a lot of people are just getting
the opportunity to see the film now
um but for me that when you watch the
film
there's a sense in which we're
addressing the idea that we're all
sort of imprisoned in a way in our own
views of the passage of time
of what's going on in the world all the
rest and so there is this kind of leap
of faith to the idea of an objective
reality
um so there's there's the idea of belief
or faith
involved with what these characters
choosing to invest in in terms of
what's really going on uh in the story
and that was always an intriguing idea
to me and i i wanted to be right
you know up front on screen all right
there you go um
next question comes from anna brushy and
many others
um this is a good one uh the protagonist
john david washington's character a lot
of people have been wondering um
why you decided to hide or not go into
um his background we know very little of
his past
what did he do before becoming a spy i
know we're gonna get answer to that but
no no the point is to not answer that uh
i i really wanted to tap into that kind
of great tradition of
the anonymous protagonist um i mean for
me it dates back to
uh you know the tv show the prisoner for
example yeah
um where he's known by a number or the
number he resists number six you know
was known as the prisoner
um but also uh i was thinking a lot of
sergio leone western slang with clint
eastwood as
you know the man with no name and all
the rest i think there's something
for me there's something really
compelling about
jumping into uh a story
and being told essentially to
concentrate on here and now
uh to pass through this experience in
the present tense
ironically it's a film that deals with
time but it's really important as you
watch the film that you're just kind of
looking over this guy's shoulder and
going with him
he's a very present tense uh presence in
the film and and so
deliberately not naming him not uh
including any of the information about
how we you know he might have arrived
there
uh i think hopefully draws attention to
that that idea and keeps people
really focused on the here and now uh
obviously john david and and
you know my discussions with john david
you know we we had to
you know have some sense he really
needed to have a uh
a sense of who this guy was and where
he'd come from uh but we really didn't
want that
uh specified in the movie i see so you
develop some of that you know kind of in
your head and john does a little bit of
that but you're not exposing it to the
audience
yeah we weren't massively pedantic about
it we weren't going through
you know who his parents were and where
he was born and all the rest
but we needed to have a sense he he
needed some guidance from me of
you know what's this guy's background
some of which is he's loosely indicated
in the script
yeah um you know the jumping off point
for the film he's clearly
you know working uh you know um the
secret service organization probably the
cia you know that and so forth
um but you know we wanna we talked about
the fact that for example he clearly has
a lot of military training and that that
kind of thing and yeah
uh but we uh we didn't want to specify
any of that for the audience
but the actor needs to know the
underlying truth of the character to
make it a
a consistent characterization that sort
of leads into this next question from uh
majorca and uh she wants to know i i can
feel the tender affection between the
conversation attitude of protagonist and
neil
did you explain to john and robert the
special relationship
between the two characters um
yeah i mean it it's i think a lot of it
was there on the page for them
actually um but then once you you cast
the film
uh because their relationship you know
as you watch the film it becomes more
and more important to the story i
suppose you'd say
um you know there are some ambiguities
to a relationship and then and then
there's a
there's a camaraderie that develops it's
very important um
a lot of that was was indicated on the
page
but once you finish a script you then
look around and say okay who can play
these parts
you put people together um
and then you know you see the chemistry
that develops and these guys
you know john david and rob pattinson um
you know they just connected and it
really really
for me it just just worked with what we
were trying to do with the with the
story it was really fun to watch these
guys work together and it's
i think it's really fun to watch the the
characters interact in the movie oh it
definitely shows on screen
um this next question comes from twitter
uh were there multiple
endings you thought of using and had to
decide from
if so what were some of them i know you
know often the ending for the film
you'll think of pretty early in the
process of kind of where you want to go
but
did you were there other scenes or you
know
not deleted scenes but sort of other
concepts of of the end of the film
i mean no the simple answer is uh
i don't go into a project without
knowing the ending because i think the
ending is
uh it's the most important part of
feature phil i think
um i think that's one of the the things
that keeps feature films very distinct
from television
because in a feature film you know you
can have a you know
a four-hour movie and the last five
minutes can let it down and then
for the audience the whole experience
gets thrown out the window um
it's it's it's like the the end of an
anecdote or a punchline to a joke like
it
it justifies everything you've seen so i
always come up with the
the ending early on and and hopefully
it's something that
uh you know it has to be something that
emerges really specifically from the
story situation that that you're
examining so no i don't sort of look at
a
mixed bag of potential endings and then
sift through them
um the only time i've ever in in my work
i've ever had sort of had
as it were multiple endings is when i
made insomnia
for warner brothers years ago they um
they were very insistent that i shoot an
alternative ending
uh i don't want to give away the ending
in the film because a lot of people
won't have seen it and maybe they'll get
to enjoy it but uh
they wanted me to shoot shoot two
different endings and i agreed to do
that
uh and uh fortunately because i'd shot
this alternate ending they never asked
to see it they knew it was in the can
and then they let me you know test
screen the the ending we all we all
loved and we went we went with that but
uh
that's really the only time i've been in
a situation where there was possibly
going to be an
alternate ending that's not generally
something i'm comfortable with at all
um speaking of the ending another
question from twitter
uh did you make a casablanca reference
in neil's last
scene line well i don't want to
have it i don't want to have any
spoilers for people who haven't seen the
film yeah yes there's very much a casper
reference in the last scene excellent
um this next question comes from uh
vishash
wants to know how do characters return
to their original timelines after
traveling
backwards um there's obviously a lot
going on with
um you know characters moving in
different timelines i assume the
question is sort of
um you know yeah how do they do they go
back to their original timeline or do
they stay on that timeline
well the question slightly
misunderstands
the rules um their timeline is their
timeline
and through the rules of inversion it it
can be inverted and they can move
backwards through time they can then
reinvert
using a turnstile and then start moving
forwards in time but they will continue
to be
uh on that timeline right so it's
awesome it'll be easier to draw a
diagram it's also one timeline it's
one uh the best way to think of it and
and this
relates to the earlier question is if
you look at john david's experience and
you follow him
through the entire story yeah that's
a single timeline that you're following
uh
but that timeline can move both forwards
and backwards and that's
where i was interested in these this of
this rule set uh because
it's quite distinct from time travel per
se or time travel movies where
multiple realities or something exactly
and they refer to the possibility of
multiple realities but the the
terms of the storytelling are pretty
tight in that you follow
this character and you're looking over
shoulder the whole way and you're you're
experiencing
his timeline on how that can meander
forwards and backwards yep
okay great um now we talk a little bit
more about some of the production pieces
of tenant this one comes from johnny
um you said that tenant brought things
that you had been thinking about for at
least 20 years
what was the moment you realized that
the script was ready
to shoot well it was
more a question of the moment i realized
that
the set of ideas was was ready to to
commit to the page in screenplay form
um i won't sit down to write something
until i kind of know that i'm ready to
and the the ideas are all in balance and
and that can take a very long time
um i'm not somebody who does a lot of
multiple drafts over the years i tend to
just take notes
and draw diagrams and think about
concepts and sort of think about okay
how could you apply that to different
forms of storytelling what might the
screenplay be
but once i've kind of focused in on on
that set of ideas and i know i'm ready
to to put it into screenplay form
that's sort of the big leap for me and
then the screenplay is a sort of
jumping off point for the execution of
you know how you're actually going to go
and make it
so i remember reading at one point that
you had sort of done i think the first
two acts and then
i mean nathan you sort of talked about
it and you were like then you're gonna
go into the third act like do you
how do you sort of tend to write this
the script do you sort of go through one
pass
i go through linearly um
and so i write the script you know from
the first frame to the last frame
and i tend to build up the drafts as i
go so i tend to rewrite
you know as i add a scene i'll very
often go right back to the beginning of
this
script and re-write through and then add
the next scene and sort of layer it that
way
every write is different everybody does
it differently um
that process works for me because i've
done so much planning before i write the
screenplay right
so i know you know where you're going i
know where i'm where i'm going in
in the sense of the narrative movements
of the narrative ideas
uh but yeah i sort of rewrite as i go um
and every now and again and this is one
of the only times i had to do you know i
had to involve nathan
at an early stage in a design sense so i
only i'd only got
two thirds of the way through so i i
made him read that which was a bit
unfair
uh and then you know carried on a month
later or something i showed him the
whole thing
wow very cool um this question comes
from sean
uh about sound design your sound design
is incredibly immersive
it seems to me more distinct than other
hollywood directors from score to sound
effects to dialogue
what is your focus when finalizing the
complete sound design what is your goal
watching tenant in theaters i felt
transported is your aim to control the
viewer's
senses and focus i mean yes
i it's an excellent question because it
it sort of answers itself
um sound and the potential of of sound
behind those big screens in in movie
theaters
uh just keeps getting better and better
and better and so you have so many
aspects to the audience experience that
you can tap into
using sound whether it's sound effects
or music and the combination of
of the two and it's it's one of my
favorite parts of the process and one of
the things i get most excited about
um with each film we try to find ways to
uh to bring something new to it to sort
of challenge the audience with it to
make them kind of feel something
uh and i think i mean i've been inspired
by
uh a lot of great filmmakers in the past
who similarly are interested in
in sound uh you know i think you know
david fincher and all the great things
he's done with sound over the years
right back to seven you know it was a an
incredible movie to watch in a movie
theater and here the way he used
backgrounds and
a lot of intrusive sound that you
wouldn't necessarily expect uh
ridley scott has done incredible work
sound over the years i mean there's so
many filmmakers who've
done a lot with it um i mean in
particular
i had to experience a few years ago of
striking a new print of kubrick's 2001
to take to the cannes film festival
and we had to lay down the soundtrack on
it so we went on a dub stage and just
laid it down exactly as it had been
recorded because we were the idea was to
give the audience the experience of what
would it have been like in 1968 to
experience that movie um and the the
sound mix was
shocking i mean it was so bold and so i
mean the
moments in there that were just
unbelievable uh you know and
extremely experimental you know for a
studio filmmaker
um so i've been inspired by all these
these terrific filmmakers over the years
and and
you know we try to we try to use it for
the tools that it can give us in terms
of storytelling and try and enjoy it a
bit
speaking of of sound uh music let's talk
a little bit about your collaboration
with
ludwig on this um one thing that i found
interesting
reading about this film is that you know
very early on i think with a lot of your
movies
the the score and you know some of the
sound you know comes in very early for
you
um it's not something where you show him
the movie and then he goes and writes it
i mean he's really part of the creative
process from
from the almost the beginning right of
sort of just coming up with sort of like
a theme or uh
yeah i mean from from script stage or
even earlier on some of my films
uh i mean i've worked with david julian
and hans zimmer and jameson howard over
the years and and
with all of them uh and ludwig was no
exception you know we talked early on
and i said
you got to understand i want i don't
like to use any temp music so i don't
like to take music from another film
while i'm editing and
put it on uh so i need the composer to
get involved
at script stage and talk about the ideas
and start writing pieces that aren't
to picture because if you look at any
film really but in particular my films
they're very quick cut
um there's a lot of stuff you know put
in there
and it's very difficult for a composer
to write for a you know
a 10 second scene or something um i want
the composer to come on
and ludwig did this very early on and
just start exploring
musical ideas that length so
10 minute pieces 20 minute pieces
sometimes and then
the technology that exists for us to
edit
that music to take it unpeel its layers
edit it together in shorter form or to
picture
you know we can do that in the edit
suite very easily
from what the composer's been doing and
then send it back to them and say okay
how does this work and you can develop
the score from
from both ends if you like yeah it's a
really fun process very dependent on
uh modern technology but technology that
that
the modern composer whether it's hanzo
or ludwig gorinson
you know these guys are all over this
stuff and and they'll give you
you know a track they'll give you a cue
that's divided into
sometimes hundreds of tracks all the
individual sounds and all the things
that you can
manipulate and play around with and and
reorder and and try them again to
picture and then sit and with ludwig
what we would do is you know we would
take his demos and we would
work with him in the week and then on
friday we would put the film up
we will sit there and watch the whole
thing from beginning to end with
whatever new
experiments we'd done with the work he'd
given us and then he would go off and
write for the next week uh we do that
for months and months so
i mean all in i think ludwig um i think
he worked on the school for over a year
uh yeah it's a big big commitment and he
did he did an incredible job i'm
absolutely thrilled with it
yeah no it's an incredible um scoring
soundtrack and
speaking of that uh riva has a question
wants to know about
travis scott being featured in the movie
um you don't normally have
uh songs in your films she says and i
know um you know that
seemed like that was maybe a somewhat
late thing that that came in right
uh with that song or was that always
planned or how did that evolve no
it wasn't always planned i've used songs
on the ends of
uh a few of my films uh there's a david
bowie song at the end of memento for
example
uh there's a tom yorke song at the end
of the prestige sometimes that energy
feels
right to me um what happened in the case
of tenet is
ludwig was getting close to the end of
the scoring um we keep watching the film
and then we started
taking cues of his and putting them on
the end
to get a feel for when the credits were
applied like what's that what's that
going to be like
um and we had a couple things we were
pretty happy with but
he and this is his genius as a composer
but also as a producer
he sort of was able to step back from
and say yeah okay
there's something about as he put it
there's something in the energy of the
film
that made you want something new at the
end that built on or was built from
things that you'd seen but wasn't a
reprise
often a reprise works really well in in
this case he felt very strongly that it
needed to be new
and he suggested getting uh travis scott
involved and
you know uh familiarize me with travis
scott's work and
great videos he's done incredible songs
and uh
i i said to luke you're like you know
it's a super exciting idea
um what do we do how would we go about
that and ludwig invited him to a
screening uh
actually in this this very uh screening
room and
uh travis cameron watched the film he
was one of the first people
uh really probably the very first person
outside of our immediate team who saw
the whole thing put together uh
and immediately had a uh a really
exciting and energetic response to it
that really showed you know he really
understood
what it was we were trying to do with
the the music and what luffy had
had laid in there so ludwig sent him
some of his tracks and he
turned them around and changed them and
and uh came up with this
fantastic song that uh i then when i
heard it we put it on the end of the
film
it felt to me like we wanted to take
some of his voice
and layer it through the rest of the
movie so
right from the first frame of the film
actually there's there's a little bit of
travis scott you know
in here and there so that by the time
you get to the end you've sort of built
up
there's a sound in your ear of his voice
that sort of pays off at the end and uh
i think all of that uh it was a really
fun collaboration and
uh i mean travis was great to work with
and it really speaks uh
of of ludwig's ability to kind of
you know he's this great genius who's
kind of in his work
but he can also step back as a sort of
producer and look at it very objectively
and say okay let's
let's bring somebody else in and and see
what we can come up with
uh it was a really really fun thing to
be a part of yeah no
super authentic and an incredible um
song uh this next question comes from
uh avon and yvonne wants to know can you
talk more about your collaboration with
jennifer lame uh the editor
i think one of the best parts of the
movie is the editing and i'm always
fascinated since you edit on film
yeah i mean it's the first film i've
done with with jen and she did an
incredible job i'd been working with lee
smith for many years and he wasn't
available for the film
uh and so i i brought jen on and she
hadn't done
uh action films before she's done some
incredible work on
ariellester's uh hereditary and so forth
and noah bomback's films
but i liked the fact that she hadn't
done anything like this
um i warned her that particularly in the
third act you know we were going to get
into
some of the some of the most complicated
and difficult editing situations that
she'd ever be faced with but
uh i was really looking for her to bring
something you know fresh to my process
in terms of all aspects of the film uh
and in particular the action and i think
she did a really incredible job
uh with the action uh we do finish the
film on film but we've always
uh edited on avid so we we shoot on film
we print the film we project it for
dailies
and then it gets scanned into the
computer we edit on the computer
we then conform as it's called you know
we take the film and we
cut that tape it together to match what
we've done on the computer and then we
project that and that's sort of
the way it uh the way it gets finished
um
so yeah she was able to uh able to keep
editing the way she learned you know on
on the avid uh but it was uh it was a
really fun
experience uh you know working with
somebody uh
who hadn't done car chases and fights it
just brought
a very fresh uh approach to it yeah and
there is a lot of action this film this
next question
um comes from anna and wants it talks
about the large-scale action sequences
including the opera sequence the 747
crash the highway scenes
and the final battle um she wants to
know which of these was the most
difficult to film um
they all had their distinct challenges
which actually
was great because they weren't none of
them were the same right
uh but they all had had huge challenges
i mean actually starting from the
what we call the vault fight you know
some of the hand-hand combat we started
with which was small scale
but it was the first start we're trying
to figure out how we were going to shoot
this stuff
um all the techniques we're going to use
so that was a huge challenge for the
first week
um the car chase was shot in talon
uh i mean i've done plenty of car chases
before but this was
you know shutting down a major route in
the city for about three weeks
very very challenging stuff forwards
backwards you know
various combinations i mean all of it
was complicated i think
in some ways i suppose you'd have to fix
on the final battle
uh as the most difficult in a sense
because there was
there's so many complexities to it we're
trying
through the film for the audience we're
trying to sort of build a level of
understanding and complexity to how this
rule set can
how you can have fun with it essentially
so every time you know we would come up
with an idea for an earlier scene that
didn't fit
we'd say okay well let's save that let's
let's see if we can explore that in
the final action and uh so it became
this kind of thing that balloon and got
bigger and bigger and bigger
uh over the months of shooting all the
other sequences and we we saved it for
the end and everybody every department
got to really
pour all their energy into into that
sequence
so i in some ways i would say that was
the most the most challenging
um but in terms of sheer physical
difficulty i think probably the
uh the foils the the sailing scene on
those
uh foils that was a very very
challenging thing to film no one had
ever filmed anything like that before
and even though it's a small in some
ways a small scene just a little
you know dialogue scene but it uh those
uh
craft i mean they're really incredible i
mean they're like the sort of
you know equivalent of formula one
racing cars or something but of
of sailboats and uh yeah they're
very challenging to work with and no one
had ever done anything like this so it
was all kind of
new ground that was that was a very
difficult sequence well
um all right we got some more questions
for you uh
more about you as sort of a filmmaker
and this one
comes from dylan carver and dylan i
think wants some advice
um greetings what would be your advice
to any small-time independent filmmaker
wanting to make the jump to celluloid
uh to celluloid in particular uh
my advice would be to get on you know
get on the internet
and see you know what kind of camera you
could get
uh there's a lot of incredible equipment
out there for very cheap
if it's in good shape and it can be
serviced and you find someone to service
it but
there's a lot of great equipment out
there a lot of great opportunities to to
start shooting celluloid
um you know and and getting in touch
with the folks at kodak
uh you know they're they're very
receptive to
lower budget filmmakers filmmakers
starting out they really want and
continue to reach out to younger
filmmakers
uh because obviously that's the the
future of celluloid is getting
new filmmakers to to come in and try it
out because i think
you inevitably find you know when a
filmmaker finally gets the chance to try
and shoot
actual film uh they love it and they
they wish they could you know always do
it and and so uh
having new filmmakers uh avail
themselves of that opportunity is very
very important um so yeah my advice
would be to get in touch with kodak and
to get in touch with uh
uh you know find a great deal on on a
camera get your own camera that would be
the way to go i think these days
absolutely um
all right this next question comes from
riley rucker since i'm involved i'm not
surprised this question came up um
would you ever want one of your films to
be adapted into a video game
and if so which one um
we've we've looked at some of them over
the years conception i think at one
point there was
we did we went fairly far down the road
with it but but of course what you
you realize is you know making films is
complicated yeah
it takes a long time making video games
is even more complicated and it takes
even longer yeah uh and the way the
video game industry works and you know
far more about it than i do
but uh it's it's
really tough to you know you can't you
don't want to just be doing a
license give you don't want to just be
tying in with something right and using
the brand established by the film
same way actually you don't when you do
you know people do a video game
adaptation
to film from a video game you don't want
it to just
draft off the brand you want it to be
something great in its own right
and uh you know i think my time and
energy
uh i've just wound up devoting it all to
film and just seeing how
how difficult that is uh you know it's
not something you'd ever take on lightly
but it's uh definitely something i i'm
interested in it's a it's an amazing
world
all right fair fair fair response um
this next one
comes from carson oak and carson wants
to know would you ever try and tackle a
horror film
the genre would be so interesting in
your style of directing
uh definitely um i
the thing about horror is it's it's the
most
purely visceral of of genres
and that is a type of filmmaking that i
am you know if you watch i mean dunkirk
in particular is one that
you know it's all about the physicality
of the
the situation for the characters and the
visceral response so that's definitely a
genre i'm i'm interested in
it's very rare to to get a great
scenario for horror movie that
really holds up and would really justify
the time there are some incredible
horror movies
uh but not that many i suppose
uh it's it's tough you know but it's
definitely something i would be
interested in exploring at some point
uh i'm in no rush shook up time try
different things but
uh it's it's certainly on my mind yeah
speaking of like
genres like horror that video game
question when you think of your career
kind of moving forward
are you intrigued by telling stories in
like in other ways i think of you know
games but even you look at like
vandersnatch and like interactive things
and things like when you think of kind
of the scripts and stories you want to
tell
explore other genres but are you
interested in other forms of sort of you
know telling stories
i i am interested in other forms but i'm
also the
the longer i work in film the more i'm
sort of
humbled by the sense of it as a medium
that it can do anything and be anything
and so in a way
i feel like i'm just scratching the
surface of what's possible in terms of
what you could do with
uh you know the theatrical film format
itself
uh so in in a way it's like i got
i've got plenty of room and it's a it's
a plain big enough playground to
to to stay in in a way uh um and so
i think yeah as i said the the longer i
work in film the more i realize that
the screen itself the form of it and
everything they're just jumping off
points for
infinite possibilities uh and so i i
i think i want to carry on doing that
what's wrong with that we'll look
forward to what's next um
sovigya wants to know have there been
times working on a script
that you thought that you'd never be
able to complete it you have that
writer's block i every day on the script
uh
yeah definitely i mean it's something
any writer deals with
a lot every problem always seems
insurmountable the
the cruel thing the cruel trick that
your mind plays on you when you when
you're writing is
you sort of go to bed at night
thinking oh i've got the whole thing
worked out and i can write it no problem
tomorrow and then you sit down and
you're like hang on
it seemed so simple till i started
writing it uh
and you're often getting stuck i mean i
think the longest i was stuck
the longest i was stuck was on inception
i you know i got to page
80 or so you know i had two acts of it
and i was stuck for about
i mean 10 years or so you know i mean i
did other things as well i wasn't
sitting here with a typewriter all work
and no play yeah it wasn't that but
you know i was i was just jammed on it
uh and then i had a breakthrough
uh and the old cliche of
if you're having trouble if there's
something wrong with the third act
it's actually wrong with the first and
second act you know that's where you
really need to do the work
uh i have always found that to be true
like if you if you're absolutely stuck
you know on that third act it probably
means that some of the groundwork you
laid in the first two acts is
is flawed somehow and with inception
that was definitely the case and i went
back and
with a new take on it and it uh it then
got finished pretty rapidly
do you tend to have a few ideas that
you're most passionate about kind of
in parallel you're thinking about or do
you singularly focus on
one project i mean it's different at
different points in my life really
um you know there's been times when i've
i've had to have
multiple things on the go i mean
certainly when we were doing the uh
dark night films um you know i was
working on other things at the same time
but those films were so big and kind of
all-consuming
um that you know along with my brother
and
david [ __ ] you know we sort of had to be
kind of finishing one
one film you know when i was uh
finishing the prestige for example i
already had nathan crowley on designing
for
the dark knight and so forth so and i'm
not generally comfortable with
doing more than one thing at a time but
there have been moments where you've
sort of had to to think about more than
one thing
what i like doing between films is
exploring a range of different ideas a
you know a whole set of possibilities
but there's always that moment for me at
any rate i mean
other filmmakers are different
everybody's different but
for me there has to be this moment where
you commit you know mentally you commit
you go okay i'm gonna
fully concentrate on this for as long as
it takes to get it done
and do you when you before you get to
that commit stage do you have like
a few ideas that are sort of populating
in your mind of different directions and
you pick one or how like what's your
kind of process of
of kind of picking the next project i
mean it's different
it's just being different it's literally
different every time it
it comes back to story simple as that
you know if you get wrapped up in the
story and you feel you know how to tell
it
then you get excited about you know all
that focus and all that concentration
and then you're creating creating a
world that you're happy to live in for a
couple years because
it takes a long time and it takes a lot
of focus at least
at least the way i work uh you know i'm
not really able to do
anything else want to make a film so uh
you know you you really have to know
that it's something you you're still
gonna care about in a couple years
yeah um this next question comes from
bojack bojack wants to know in your
formative years did you ever have a
mentor
who played a part in who you are as a
filmmaker today
hmm i mean so many great inspirational
figures in in film
but the wonderful thing about film and
the era i've grown up in you know uh
as as really the i suppose the first you
know home video generation film
set of filmmakers of my age you know so
you know we got our first
vhs player in the early 80s when i was
you know 12 years old or something
and and so i've been able to grow up
with inspirational figures
in my creative life who i i never met
and i never
you know had that particular mental
relationship with i mean my parents were
very encouraging of me and
and you know lent me a super eight
camera you know
super eight film you know when i was a
little kid who was seven
eight years old um but i think
i would point to being able to access
all of film history
through home video and so you know i was
able to study the work of
you know ridley scott and nicholas rogue
and later on you know terence malik and
kubrick and people like that um i then
had the great fortune of being able to
meet
you know some of these people you know
met uh the great terence malik who have
met ridley scott
uh you know and that that's a wonderful
thing but but you can
have that and for kids today it's even
more so i mean everything is accessible
so easily
uh which is a great thing because you
can you can really drill into
okay what are the great filmmakers of
the past what have they done and how
have they done it and really sort of
study that for yourself yeah um
this next question is about imax uh
jacob wants to know what is your
favorite shot
that you have captured with an imax
camera
hmm
you know in some ways it'd be difficult
to pick favorites
uh but i probably have to go
with the opening shot of the dark knight
which was
sequentially the first thing we
we did on on imax or at least the first
thing we showed you an audience in imax
and every time we ever screened the film
for an audience there was a gasp at that
shot
moving in on the building like that uh
and
and that was it was thrilling to see
people kind of respond to just the
format itself
and the shot um it'd be a toss-up
between that and the shot of
uh heath ledger's standing on the corner
that comes right after it you know
holding a mask in his hand i mean that
there's something about that it was it
was
another filmmaker actually came up to me
and talked about it was actually james
cameron
um because he had talked about shooting
on imax for many
years years ago and i'd first read about
you know his idea about well you you
shoot larger format negative and you
extract the 35 mil
portion yeah so that stuck in my head
and that was eventually what we
you know years later actually did uh you
know on the dark knight and
and you know he told me when he saw that
shot he knew that
it was going to work you know that the
format and the formatting the way we've
done it would would work
there is some special relationship with
that imax frame and that shot of
he's standing there in the corner um so
there's a couple
um and then we've gone on to do so many
uh things that i've just loved doing
with the imax camera
uh but there's something about those
those first couple things this first
well we didn't know if it would work
that was the thing so to see that it
worked that was a
a unique thrill yeah an incredible
sequence um
this next question comes from ethan uh
ethan wants to know what would you say
was the most challenging film of yours
to make
and why hmm
um i mean they've all been challenging
in their own ways
uh you know i find filmmaking incredibly
fulfilling but i do find it hard
um i think if you were to ask my crew
i think dunkirk reads pretty highly it's
a difficult film
um i actually didn't find it so i mean i
don't mind the weather and all of those
conditions and there was a real focus
and a small
cool group of us you know around the
camera on that film so i actually
enjoyed that one
um i think tenet was was very difficult
because of
the range of uh action set pieces we
were trying to do and how much of the
the world we were trying to cover the
combination of that
with the unique sort of um difficulty
of visualizing uh
how the timelines have of how the the
opposing uh timelines
would work with this concept of
inversion um it was something that
wasn't possible to intuit so however
long i worked with the idea
you could write it on the page you could
analyze it and describe it but until you
actually started
seeing the footage you couldn't fully
engage with it you couldn't fully
understand it so every day on set
we had a big group of people sitting
talking about okay hang on does this
happen before this and all the rest
um and the way we dealt with that in the
end was to have the visual effects guys
do what they call previous you know
pre-visual visualization
of um the scene but not from a camera
perspective from a sort of it's like a
top-down diorama yeah kind of top-down
you could look at it at any angle and
just look at
the logic of that and so um
you know bodhi on onset worked for the
visual effects department
he would be my gut he'd always have his
laptop and he'd say okay
tell me this does this happen before
that is that you know whatever
and he would every time he would start
to answer and said don't answer
because you'll probably be wrong we
always are when we try and intuit it
go away and study it for 10 minutes then
come back and tell me uh so that that
was how that went down but
that made it a very unique set of
challenges particularly for me because
i'm the one i'm the guy who has to have
the answers on set you know because
the actors or technicians whatever
you're saying on how do you want this
how do you want that
and i had a good sense of things but one
of the things i found really exciting
about working on this movie is
you had to shoot it you have to see it
to understand it you
to know what it is it wouldn't it
doesn't really work
fully as a screenplay it couldn't be a
novel it couldn't be a stage play or
radio play like it has to be a movie
because the camera itself sees time and
can show us time in different ways and
that's what the whole
concept is based on it's okay let's look
at time
differently let's look at the action of
a big action movie differently
by approaching time differently you have
to see it you have to experience the
movie to kind of know what it's on about
yeah i can't imagine the the continuity
department on this trying to you know
pull like
did you ever did you ever trip yourself
up at some point and say like oh wait no
i you know we changed this or like you
know
there's so much so many things going on
in so many levels you know it's
interesting i made mistakes all the time
um while i was writing the script
i was pleased to find out as we started
translating the script into previews and
and answering all the questions that i
hadn't made very many mistakes in the
script that i was sort of pleased about
i got into some kind of
way of looking at it that actually
seemed to work when you when you then
looked at it
objectively or kind of built the model
of it um
but every day on set uh
i like everybody else you would you
would you'd be thinking procedurally
about what order things happen
and you make one mistake early on in
your thinking then
everything else is cascading and we
would all do it all the time
and the problem with that kind of
cascading set of assumptions
or mistakes is that you because you
don't know you've made an error
in in the beginning of your thinking you
are absolutely convinced
you can you can see it you can and there
was a
it was interesting there was a level of
humility that developed for everybody
on the set where we all sort of learn to
not commit
actually and to say i think it's this
but let's talk it through
uh which i should become a fun process
in the end did you ever
like did you have to reshoot something
or did you catch it early enough or i'm
curious how that like
manifested itself we i think the only
time we made an
actual sort of a mistake was in the
first week where we
ran the camera the wrong way for the way
we were staging the scene
uh and that was the kind of mistake you
know that we expected to make a lot but
having
having done it once you know in the
first week uh we got pretty methodical
about it like the camera guys you know
had to
uh film magazines for forwards film
magazines for backwards and the back
which ones they had kind of
black and white checkered tape all over
it and everything so they would never
pick the wrong one
um and we learned i think the reason we
didn't make mistakes is we learned
and film units these guys are really
good at doing this stuff this way or you
just systematize it
so you don't nothing's casual nothing's
you know i mean if you watch a camera
crew on a
hollywood set the way they will pick up
the camera the way everything is
systematized they do it the same every
time so they know exactly
to not make mistakes uh and that
got applied to our thinking in terms of
how we would answer questions and how we
would
we would make plans as we would talk it
through in a particular way
and then sign off on it once we'd you
know kind of
kind of done that process the tricky
thing is on a big film you actually have
to be thinking
about the next thing at the same time
and the thing after that you kind of got
to be two or three
set ups as we call them two or three
setups ahead to stay on schedule and
that's where it got really tricky
because you'd
if you're talking about you know you're
solving one problem and if i would start
talking about the next one
as part of that conversation which is
what i'm used to doing to keep going
it would throw everything and so it had
to be a little more a little more linear
wow um next question comes from duncan
uh duncan wants to know did you watch
any film for reference
before you started to write tenet
um no not really
uh i
well actually you know what for my own
writing process
i watched a lot of fritz lang movies uh
fritz lang spies in particular
uh i get a lot of inspiration from going
back to the silent era
because it's just a completely different
set of conventions then
and so you can be really inspired by it
it's sort of going back to what i call
first principles of
filmmaking you know there's they're not
dealing with any of the things that
we're dealing with
in the modern world and so you you're
getting a really fresh look at genre and
i think fritz lang
uh in his work uh he's this incredible
way of looking at
the fanciful the fanciful villains and
so forth
integrated into a recognizable world uh
they're really inspiring from that point
of view so i i did a bit of that but
then when we actually came to
to make the film we didn't watch a lot
of other movies and you tend to do that
sometimes we do we usually do screenings
and we didn't on this one
partly because it's a spy genre
and that's such a well-established genre
i felt like i didn't want to
revisit those i know this film so well i
know the bond films so well and the born
movies that also so
it's kind of in there already and
you don't really want to be looking at
the specifics of it you kind of want to
just go with the general inspiration
from it
all right and last question comes from
twitter this is a
thought-provoking one what has been the
project that has impacted you
the most chris tough one to answer
really uh
you know they all are experiences for me
and for
my family um you know you you go through
things for for years um i suppose i
would
probably have to point to momento as the
the single biggest impact
because it was a a process of going
through being a fully independent
filmmaker where we were just you know
literally shooting with friends and
family and catches catch can and
putting 16 mil films together and sort
of spending other people's money
uh and then the success of that film uh
opened all kinds of
possibilities uh you know for us and
tell us how we would
maybe get to tell bigger and bigger
stories um but
they've all they've all had you know an
extraordinary
impact on our lives one way or the other
because they're just
experiences that you go through for for
years and i and i love to work with
you know friends and family and so
they're kind of communal experiences for
all of us that we go through
yeah well this certainly has been a
non-traditional release for for this
film but for for those of you at home
that uh have not experienced tenant uh
it is available now
on 4k ultra hd blu-ray and digital uh an
incredible film from an incredible
filmmaker christopher nolan thanks so
much for uh for joining us
and uh thank you we'll look forward to
the next one thanks very much
you